hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for another south by southwest
2022 interview with
one of my absolute favorites i'll say
that and someone that i'm very excited
to meet for the first time we have some
of the team behind the movie pretty
problems with us please welcome director
question pantera and we also have one of
the film stars vanessa chester vanessa
i'll just put you on the spot right from
the start because everyone on this
channel knows that i am like way too
obsessed with the jurassic franchise so
it's it's like i've been like
for you and rooting for kelly since way
back in the day oh my gosh i'm so
honored this is amazing thank you yes
well kelly's here and ready to chat with
you harry
kester i have to make you blush now like
you are hands down one of my favorite
south by southwest interviews of all
time and following uh your movie through
to actual release was like one of the
greatest joys and a bright spot in the
pandemic so i'm so happy to be back here
celebrating another one with you oh
thank you
and that was an ugly cry sound thank you
i bought it i watched it all right so a
festival premiere for this movie of
course so our viewers will likely not
know what pretty problems is just yet so
kestren can i give the duties to you can
you give us a brief synopsis of your
movie
yes absolutely pretty problems is what i
hope to be a south by southwest breakout
comedy there are a lot of really
important films being created
and i'm very proud to say that this is
not one of them
this is made to make you laugh um it's a
story about
a couple who get swept away on a
billionaire weekend kind of living the
life stream that many of us may or may
not have
and then um when the cracks in their
marriage and reality start to break they
are forced to you know reckon with their
inner demons
um
and it was a joy to get to go to an
amazing billionaire compound in the
sonoma region for three weeks to live
and shoot the film
oh i have so many questions that one
before we get too far ahead of ourselves
can you walk us through how the film
came to be for you because some brief
googling showed me how the dots connect
between brit michael and charlotte but
did you know them before they brought
you the script
very good question the answer to that is
that britt rentschler is a witch
she emailed me cold out of the blue and
wrote this perfectly phrased email that
was essentially we have this hilarious
script it shoots in this billionaire
compound a lot of the cast is secured
and it's fully financed would you like
to take a look and i was like
how do you not say no to that did she
ever tell you what it was about your
work that made her send you of all
people that email yes she did say that
it was mother's little helpers she loved
the trailer that we released for
distribution
and
she was really into the performances of
breeda wool melanie hutzel sam
littlefield melania vince have been the
and the the folks of mother's little
helpers and said that it was her wish
that she could get similar performances
out of herself and her friends
well great success in that respect yet
again uh vanessa for you what about the
beginning stages who reached out to you
to get involved and what piqued your
interest about the opportunity the most
so just to take it back a little bit i'm
not sure exactly when but keshan and i
met i want to say five or six years ago
at a pool party
we didn't know each other and kathryn
did the one thing that i'm always hoping
someone would do which is take a candid
photo of me when i look cute and she did
it and she did such a good job and she's
been taking amazing photos of me ever
since
and as we became better friends i just
started realizing like oh my gosh this
woman is an absolute genius like i love
the way her mind works i love the way
she sees the world and then the way she
executes what she sees so she hit me up
and was like hey
um i'm doing this film and it's gonna be
on this billionaire's compound and like
jj's going and i was like well first of
all my friends are there so like i
haven't seen friends in forever i read
the script and i was like wait stop we
did like a fun little zoom where she
just had me like
play around a bit and it was
just even thinking back to that zoom it
was so much fun i was like oh wait this
is visceral joy going through my brain
like my veins right now it was just
we just played and then she hit me up a
couple days later and was like hey they
really liked what you did and i was like
they did
and then i ended up in the film
i loved that so much so it doesn't
surprise me to hear that it's a whole
bunch of friends getting together and
making a movie because i get that vibe
from both films and i kind of love it so
time to make kestren blush even more
vanessa for you when you hit the set
that she's at the helm of what is
something that she does to kind of set
the tone and create a great environment
that you appreciated and which you saw
more sets out there
i think
from like trying to speak as if i didn't
know kestrin
her energy is so grounding and it's so
comfortable to be around her and work
with her and i think that the thing that
is the most important when you're on set
especially as an actor is
an environment where you feel like
communication is accepted and freely
flows and the thing that was so awesome
about working with question was
how open and receptive she was to advice
to playing around and just the whole
process of collaborating and it was just
something that you could see just
trickle down through every single person
on the set and i i attribute it all to
you like you were the top of the pyramid
and just gave us all this incredible
energy and the actual resources to feel
supported to deliver the performances
that we did it was just i want to work
with you every day come over right now
okay mine coming over okay
bye
which scene of the film required the
most playing around in workshopping gosh
i think i mean vanessa's scene had a ton
of it i mean i think honestly all right
every scene is kind of goes the exact
same way so it's not like there's more
or less workshopping in any scene we
would shoot it as written because that
we got an amazing script and then
people would slowly let their insane
ideas
seep into it and then it would morph by
the end usually they would just nail the
first take as written and then i would
be like all right let's start riffing
and you know
actors are often smarter than me they're
better at their character than i am but
their character they've certainly
thought about it more than i ever have
so there's so much to
contribute uh there's so much to receive
from an actor's contribution so i just
like hire the smartest weirdest people
and then get it as written and then just
let them go completely bonkers more
people should take that approach i guess
it works
you also have a very clear vision of
what you want and i think that that
speaks with everything that you do like
you know exactly what's in your head and
you can tell when a director is just in
their element because the minute you got
it you were like that's it and you were
like and we move on because we got it
and it's just like wow
you were standing in your power you know
exactly what you want and you brought
out the best of everyone
i love this conversation so much already
uh vanessa running with one of the ideas
that kestren just brought up what did
gigi look like on the page and then what
did you bring to her that wasn't there
to start
well i am so lucky because i am a very
visual and like my imagination is wild
and when i when question sent me the
script and then i read it and she told
me what she was thinking of i was like
okay first of all
this is every single friend of mine who
went and did an ayahuasca ceremony in
2019 like this is it i get to be the
shaman that's leading this so i was
already
completely grounded in it just because
of the fun but what i said to question
was you know
i think what would make this character
the most interesting is if the audience
can't tell whether or not she's fake
like we don't know whether or not what
she's saying
is actually so enlightened that we don't
get it or if she's actually full of [ __ ]
and i thought that that was really fun
to play with i was like the only thing
that i think is important is that gigi
takes herself very seriously and it's up
to the audience to decide if she's on to
something or not and after watching it
i'm still not sure i don't know which
way she goes
i mean the whole movie kind of has that
vibe so castron it makes me want to ask
you about because you emphasize the the
comedy in your description of the movie
but there is that kind of absurdist
nature to it but then there's also these
like underlying themes and like like
real uh real human truths that i imagine
many people out there when they hit a
certain age probably in particular wind
up experiencing so what was it like kind
of balancing that there
you're basically asking like what's it
like to direct a movie that's like equal
parts american pie and con scenes from a
marriage or like marriage story um there
is a really raw
relationship rift that's happening
between the two protagonists of this
film and they do ask some really
honest vulnerable questions and they do
have some very authentic genuine fights
that i think anyone who's been in a
relationship can
identify with like it gets ugly it gets
weird
and it does tie into the concept of
abundance versus lack right like we all
have an awareness of what it is like to
have more than someone else no matter
who you are or what you have you know
what it's like to have more than someone
else and you also know exactly what it's
like to have far less than another so
for me it was about
finding that like ookiness that you get
when you're like bigger when you feel
like guilty for having more than someone
else and also the ookiness of like
i'm not enough here and i can't measure
up to these people so i'm kind of like
trying to prove myself and then just
shine a light on that disgusting
ookiness and then just forgive us all
and release us all from it like you're
fine
you're normal
i feel like i'm gonna repeat disgusting
ookiness somewhere
yeah i was like ookie's a vibe i want to
do that i'll take that
i want to normalize goopy for 2022.
i will get behind that campaign
so question here i guess this is kind of
like a less is more question here but i
know you've done this on a short film or
two maybe but what is it like solely
focusing on directing this film and not
acting in it as well do i guess like new
or different tools or techniques become
available to you when you're only
wearing the one hat i felt like
i had a protagonist in this movie who
was a writer and producer
and uh
i remember at one point i almost felt
like i became him like our like avatar
teals like intertwined like our navels
like their tail you know what i mean
when like
feels like a vocal so i felt like i just
transferred my experience starring in a
movie and directing it onto my
protagonist michael
and tried to protect him from all the
traps that i had learned when i was on
camera and directing and that came
across as like
i see you right now
as a writer watching other people and
judging how they're
doing their line reads and right now you
need to like be an actor and only
act
and
it's a really weird vulnerable thing i
mean he's he said this where he's like
he said that i told him to i was like
michael you need to stop tying
everyone's shoes like knock it off and
um
and so for me i kind of put all that
life force into empathy for
for his position because i knew it so
intimately
and was just trying to like protect him
and protect his performance so that he
could be as vulnerable as possible and
in service to the story that he had
written and not like up in his gourd
very understandable there all right
looping in some more of the cast here so
vanessa you get a pretty big sequence
towards the end of the film what is it
like jumping on set with a bunch of
people who have probably been working
together the entire time and kind of you
know picking up their way of working in
their rhythm
well it's interesting you know
it's it's
it's funny because the minute you said
that the image that came in my head is
like going to a new school where you
know like
two people
and so the two people for me was like i
was the new kid on campus and everyone
had been working for at least a week or
two you know they have a whole vibe and
energy going and i like kind of walked
in and i was like first of all where are
we where are we and i'm not leaving just
know that i'm here now i'm never leaving
and i was just
a little nervous i don't think i'm ever
not going to be nervous and i think
that's why i continue doing this but
question and jj
cat who plays cat i've known them
forever so i got on set and was just
like oh my gosh my friends so i'm
immediately comfortable and then
i've never said this to you question but
maybe it's because you're a mama but you
have like this incredible ability
to take care of everyone like i felt
very taken care of the fact that you
just said like you were talking about
telling michael like stop tying
everyone's shoes you you literally tie
and velcro everyone and so
you know i brought it back to the 80s
like velcro shoes but it's like
it's one of those things where i jumped
on set and i felt so supported and it
was one of those things where whenever
you know we try out for something as an
actor they're like have fun
play with it it's like what are you
talking about like this is my job i care
about this let's take it seriously
and this is one of the first projects
where i was like oh like
i knew what i was doing but that wasn't
work that was all fun
like i stepped into a new situation and
felt like i was just late and everyone
was expecting me because it was that
welcoming when vanessa showed up i will
i will
to to to your what was it like on
vanessa's first day as an outside
observer i did notice that we were
having a pool party and she jumped right
in to the pool
it
whatever nerve she was feeling uh like
energetically she was like a one
cannonball like into just the vibe of
everyone i was literally like oh snap
i'm late for the party let me get a
drink real quick
one of those things i was like oh snap
i'm late for the party i'm definitely
filming tomorrow but like we're in the
jacuzzi right now so that's important
when you've got a shooting location like
that i 100 percent understand like
getting into that vibe asap
all right kestren how about
the reframe stamp can you give our
viewership a little bit of a 101 on how
you get one and then why it was
important for you to have one on this
film
the reframe stamp is something that is
awarded by the sundance institute and
women in film in partnership with imdb
that recognizes films that have gender
parody above and below the line so that
means for our film it was that every
department head was a woman
um and that and
you know over 50 of all of our caster
crew were women in poc
and um
that
you know for me
it was great to be recognized for that
officially but
my last movie was exactly the same i
kind of always have female department
heads not because i'm
necessarily trying to it's just that's
who
kind of emerged at the at the right time
in the right place for the right
position
so there were a lot of moments where we
would be on set and people would be
looking around with on gratitude being
like look at the look at all these women
behind the camera and i was like
duh like what we do every single time
like we should really give guys a shot
like
you know we should create some
opportunities though i'm just kidding
like they
there were so
there's always all female camera
operators on my set so i'm really used
to it but i'm really glad that the
reframe stamp is something that we were
recognized
with and that uh other people's minds
were surprised by what they saw and i'm
also glad that it's just normal for me
i love that all right i have one random
question because i was watching the
credits all the way through and i love
spotting names that i recognize and the
special thanks john watts like
spider-man john watts
uh john watts is amazing he um
when i first moved to los angeles and
they and and he had this company waverly
films they would shoot a lot of
music videos and commercials and when i
was an actor when i first came out here
i learned a lot of my directing skills
and editing from just hanging out on
their sets and being a part of like the
wallflowers video that he was directing
and
you know watching how they would comp
stuff and he was you know kind enough to
give me feedback and notes on this movie
and just i feel really grateful but to
have him as a
mentor and you know supporter and friend
and colleague
that's awesome
just because everything we've been
talking about with the environment on
this set and him directing a big marvel
movie is making me want to ask you i
don't even know if you're interested in
something like this but if an
opportunity ever came to direct like one
of those big studio movies would you
want to take it because again based on
this conversation i just want like i
want these vibes to get out there on an
even bigger scale
absolutely i mean that was actually why
i reached out to john where i was like
i've done a movie
you know that's really small that's like
flying a little piper aircraft you know
that's like a two-seater and this one
was a bit bigger and i wanted to know
what it's like to be on a 747 like
you're all you're always flying it's the
same principles of flight it's just you
have a up-leveled control panel so that
was actually the email i wrote him was
called up leveling the control panel um
you know asking him about you know his
insights on that and yes i absolutely
would love to and john's a huge
inspiration because what i loved about
all of his spider-man movies is just
they're funny and the acting's really
good the story's great and but he's
really got the foundational elements of
like a killer story and just amazing
totally
hilarious joy in his actor's
performances and that's exactly what i
want to do i would love to direct
something
for marvel studios for disney i actually
do have my heart set on
in some iteration
uh
the live-action reboot of the aristocats
for disney that would be my life's dream
oh my god when i saw that news when it
broke i'm like whoa they're doing it and
i'm psyched for it and i would hand that
to you in a heartbeat
well you know that my cat actually was
on set for the filming of pretty
problems for three weeks on location in
in the sonoma valley
um
so that's something photos cat i've got
a lot of great photos of keshan with the
cat this is obviously another reason why
your work speaks to me so much because i
can feel the cat energy is coming off of
it all it's great actually a dog in in
your previous film though so animal
lover all around i'll take animal lovers
always put them in put the cat in the
movie dog in the movie yeah all right
i've kept you both for a while you've
got a south by southwest journey to kick
off huge congratulations on the new
movie and thank you so much for talking
to us about it